many residents of ottawa are breathing a
sigh of relief tonight after three weeks
of complaints about harassment noise and
unease during the demonstration sean
o'shea joins us from inside the security
zone so sean you were out speaking with
residents today what did they have to
say jeff we set out to
do east of here to the byward market
area that's an area that's very popular
with both tourists and with locals alike
and many businesses most businesses in
that area were closed on friday and
saturday because of the police action
and the
biggest shopping mall or one of the
biggest shopping malls in canada the
redo center remains closed after three
weeks
now some residents did venture out today
many for the first time in a while
they told us they were relieved that the
protesters and those trucks have finally
gone here's what some of them had to say
to us earlier
it's just wonderful to walk out and not
have to worry about being actually
harassed or harmed it's great it feels
great that uh like my friend was saying
that things are getting back to normal
and while yeah there's a heavy police
presence now at least
at least it's the police and not a bunch
of random people from outside of our
city coming in and
shutting everything down and i think
some of these businesses
probably are really hurting for patrons
so i thought okay let's walk around
let's see what's what's going on and see
if we can you know get a coffee
somewhere or walk around and just see
what's open now not everything is back
to normal those are some of the prisoner
transport vehicles just down here from
parliament hill
the war memorial there there were some
officers taking photos there this area
is still all sealed off so things are
definitely not back to normal as people
in ottawa know normal but those
protesters who had been here for three
weeks they have gone the honking is gone
the diesel has gone and at some point at
some point this area will be restored to
what people in ottawa know as normal we
just do not know when that will happen
as yet